[Music]
hi John as Monday April 23rd here we are
at Westview fun gameplay fun center
place in the West what does it feel like
when you when you pick up a spare Bob
well when a pickup spare wheels even
better than riding it good girlfriend
and I know John
that was acclaimed naturalist an
award-winning nature writer Robert
Michael Pyle RMP or Bob or Rob Bob as we
call him was a visiting professor at my
university a couple years ago and took a
classroom he's an all-around SuperDuper
guy and is tons of fun to bowl with he
had a lot to do with me becoming a
writer uh just like you did so it's nice
to kind of introduce you to each other
John I should let you know that I'm
extremely proud of your mathematics that
was some excellent calculating you did
you hit it right on the head there 940
something bound to carbon not something
I'm necessarily proud of but our videos
have been watched over a hundred
thousand times a hundred thousand times
that's a lot of video watching something
like six thousand hours of people
watching our videos hold on I'm getting
the calculator if we had to actually pay
people for the time that they gave us
and we had to pay the minimum wage it
would have cost us over thirty thousand
dollars brotherhood 2.0 even without a
living wage has cost the world thirty
thousand dollars of time if anyone had
ever wondered how exactly this works
this is how this works thank you for
that thirty thousand dollars of time
we're going to use it to decrease
worldsuck somehow frankly it's good to
know that more hours go into watching
this video then into making it someone
has asked in the comments how long it
takes to make one of these videos and
that's kind of hard to say because I
don't just make the video and read a
story to yuku geek I come back and I
record some video and then I go get some
breakfast I come back and record some
more video but on the days when I really
concentrate it takes a minimum of two
hours it's good to be appreciated it's
good to be appreciated to the tune of
126 votes at the boggers Choice Awards
holy freaking moly he are catching up to
YouTube now I know that we're not the
biggest video blog project out there but
there are a lot of people watching me
talk to you and that's weird
so I want to thank them and I want to
say if you're at brotherhood 2.0 right
there also there's been a little bit of
talk about me being on someone's free
pass list a free pass list is a list of
celebrities that you get to do if you
ever get the chance to do first of all
apparently I'm a celebrity second of all
apparently I'm on someone's free pass
list and people are asking if I'd like
to comment on that I would not like to
comment on that I'm fine with it I am a
little bit disappointed that I came in
after brian setzer
now I would like to say to the Yeti
aunty Katherine who I know are watching
done and I don't have a free pass lists
except maybe Helen Hunt and now that
I've let that little bit slip I guess
I'll see you tomorrow